That ends this section specifically
on Particle Filtering.
You've now seen the algorithm
in some details.
State and dynamics and censor models.
And the really good thing
about particle filters is that
you can make them as
complicated as you want.
But you can start off simple and
get something running.
You then have to worry about how, how
many dimensions are in your state space,
because if you get too many, then you
might have to have too many particles.
You have to worry about re-initializing.
We talked about that before,
of scattering some particles around
in order to you know,
in case something has happened quickly
that you didn't anticipate there
would be some particles there.
But the good news is it,
it's really quite accessible,
there's a lot of papers to read.
You can actually start with
that condensation paper.
It, it really lays it out.
In fact, there's a conference version of
it, that came out even earlier that I
think is even clearer
because it has less detail.
So so I hope most of you will get,
will get to understand that.
And certainly the OMS students,
you will, as you will be
doing it on the problem set.